à Brasilia des centaines d'évangéliques
se sont rassemblés sur la place des
trois pouvoirs pour prier pour le
président Jaïr bolsonaro durant les deux
heures du tout dernier débat télévisé
d'une interminable campagne
ce n'est pas eux que bolsonaro doit
convaincre dans le studio de TV Globo il
a besoin des indécis et des
abstentionnistes du premier tour pour
rattraper son retard sur l'ex-président
Lula
en présence de ces conseillers dont le
juge Sergio Moreau devenu sénateur qui a
mis Lula en prison il y a 4 ans Jair
bolsonaro est repassé à l'attaque
mensonge menteur ce sont les mots qui
ont été le plus entendus des deux côtés
pendant les deux heures de débat en fait
de débat plutôt de monologues remplies
d'invectives Lula a été traité de voleur
bandit chef de mafia de corrompu pour le
scandale de petrobrass Lula marqué des
points à propos de la pandémie il promet
de redonner au Brésil son prestige perdu
avec bolsonaro le pays est devenu
impérial dit-il nous faire mauvais nous
les Brésiliens vivent avec anxiété les
dernières heures de la campagne en jeu
rien de moins que la démocratie de
retour depuis 1989 on doit choisir entre
un projet autoritaire
qui menace les niveaux les plus éliminés
d'une démocratie et un autre qui même si
on n'a pas d'accord avec ses projets
politiques au niveau économique au
niveau
social au moins c'est un projet qui
reste dans le cadre de la démocratie
pourtant les Brésiliens ils tiennent à
la démocratie c'est le choix politique
de 79% d'entre eux mais presque la
moitié d'entre eux vont voter pour
quelqu'un qui la menace en fait ça c'est
une station qui qu'on appelle des
paradoxes de la démocratie parce que
partout dans le monde les gens
manifestent leur adhérence à la
démocratie mais en même temps il
manifeste aussi l'air critique aux
partis politiques qui sont justement la
caractéristique principale d'une
démocratie il y a pas de démocratie
sympathie politique
qu'il respecterait le résultat des
élections il a dit celui qui a le plus
de votes gagne reste à savoir que s'il
per avec résultats serré il ne va pas
prétendre qu'il y a eu fraude comme il
l'a laissé entendre maintes fois
auparavant Jean-Michel Leprince
Radio-Canada Rio